When thinking about how to address the
virtualization requirements that we just
mentioned in the previous quiz,
it is fortunate to observe that
commodity hardware actually has
more than two protection levels.
Looking at the architecture that's,
at least in the server space, most
dominant, the x86 architecture, there
are four protection levels called rings.
Ring 0 has the highest privilege and
can access all of the resources and
execute all hardware-supported
instructions.
And this is where in a, a native model,
the operating system would reside.
So, when the OS is in control of all the
hardware resources, it sits in ring 0.
In contrast, ring 3 has
the least level of privilege, so
this is where the applications
would reside.
And whenever the applications try to
perform something, some operation for
which they don't have the appropriate
privileges, then a trap would be caused,
and control would be switched to the
ring 0, to the lowest privileged level.
One way in which these protection levels
can be used is to put the hypervisor
now in ring 0, so that's the one that
has full control over the hardware,
to leave the applications to
execute at ring 3 level, and
then the operating system
would execute at ring 1 level.
We'll explain how this actually
works in the following video.
More recent x86 architectures also
introduce two different protection modes
called root and non-root.
Within each of these modes,
the four protection levels exist, so
there are like two times
these protection rings.
Now, when running in root mode,
all of the operations are permitted,
all hardware is accessible,
all instructions can be executed.
So, this is the highest privilege level.
And this is,
the ring 0 of the root mode,
is where we would run the hypervisor.
In contrast, in non-root mode, certain
types of operations are not permitted.
So then, the guest VMs would
execute in this non-root mode.
And they would have,
as they did in the native execution,
their applications running in ring 3 and
the operating system running
at ring 0 privilege level.
Attempts by the guest operating system
to perform privileged operations
cause traps that are called VMexits.
And these trigger a switch to this root
mode and pass control to the hypervisor.
When the hypervisor
completes its operation,
it passes control back to the virtual
machine by performing a VMentry which
switches the mode into non-root mode, to
ring 0, so that the execution continues